one former and one current university
professor argue that America's colleges
and universities have lost sight of
educating students according to the
authors the nation's higher education
system is a four hundred twenty billion
dollar per year business that's more
interested in making money demos in New
York City is the host of this hour and
15-minute talk good evening and welcome
I'm David Callahan a senior fellow at
demos it's great to have you all here
for a provocative discussion about
higher education that is jointly
co-sponsored by demos in the world
Policy Institute so my advice for the
audience tonight is to fasten your seat
belts and if there are any sacred cows
in the room they should run for their
lives the book is called a higher
education with a huge question mark
dominating the cover and a very unsubtle
subtitle how colleges are wasting our
money and failing our kids and what we
can do about it
these days everybody takes for granted
that getting a college education is a
good thing the VA today is the
equivalent of a high school diploma a
half century ago and when many of us do
fret about higher education we tend to
worry that too many people can't afford
to go to college here at dmoz we have
been working for years to expand access
to higher education most recently with
our work on community colleges well
tonight we're going to have a very
different kind of conversation about
college to be sure the concerns about
access will be here and run throughout
but we're also going to hear a
remarkably sweeping and harsh critique
of higher education along with some
pretty
radical ideas for change the authors of
this book are no strangers to this
subject and who hacker has been teaching
on campuses for 55 years first at
Cornell University and then at Queens
College a hundred and ten consecutive
semesters whatever happened to the
sabbatical beyond his teaching he has
been a prolific writer no doubt you've
seen his work in the New York Review of
Books he is author of a 1992 bestseller
about race a 1998 book about money a
2003 book about gender differences
Claudia Dreyfus also knows her way
around a campus she is an adjunct
professor of International Affairs and
media at Columbia University and before
that she taught at the Graduate
Department of English at the City
University of New York and she too is a
prolific writer she is best known as a
journalist interviewer for the New York
Times science section and she is the
author as well in previous books in
addition she is a senior fellow at the
World Policy Institute the world Policy
Institute by the way is a nonpartisan
Center for progressive global thought
leadership based here in New York and
publisher of the world policy journal
Deimos is a national public policy
organization also based here in New York
with offices in Washington and Boston
now the book under discussion tonight
has been praised by so many
distinguished people in very glowing
terms so glowing in fact that I think it
would make the author's blush if I
actually read through all the comments
from people like Joseph Stiglitz and
Barbara Ehrenreich so let's spare than
that you can read the blurb yourself
when you buy the book after the event
instead let's get on with
the discussion we're not going to have
any any prepared remarks we're just
going to jump straight into the
questions and we're gonna do questions
with with me and the authors for a bit
and then we'll bring you all in so I
guess I'd like to start with you Claudia
and and ask you know you'd spend a lot
of time in higher education in many ways
it's been very good to you and this is a
pretty harsh book and so I guess I'd
like to just hear the story of how you
came to write this book and why and you
know what what do you all hope to
accomplish with it well the book really
began for me when I started teaching in
the 90s and I I'm very I should say I'm
very happy teaching at the school that I
teach it now which is Columbia
University's Graduate School of
International Affairs but the place that
I taught before was in the middle of a
crisis
political crisis and funding crisis and
coming from the world of journalism
which is very practical very go to it
very real world just going into this
what seemed to me an alternate culture
that was absolutely the opposite in the
middle of a crisis and unable to cope
with it really troubled me I felt very
out of place in that culture I felt that
they were letting the students down in a
very very bad way I saw that the
institution seemed to function only for
the tenured faculty and it my opinion
left everyone else out and both the
students and the adjuncts really
suffered and it wasn't even a question
of politics people who worked there on
the Faculty of war would consider
themselves tremendously progressive in
many ways and yet there was something
terribly wrong there and it troubled me
and so when Andrew and I became life
partners in our real life we wanted to
work together and here he is a professor
who writes I'm a writer who professes
that so so it would be natural that we
birth a book and why not look around our
own lives that's the beginning the book
is pretty harsh though
well I think what's going on needs a
harsh look I've never encountered a
world in all my years as a journalist as
unselfie collective as the world of
higher education people do not look at
themselves they do not look at what's
wrong
they're closed unfortunately to any kind
of criticism and there are tremendous
problems this is a very unexamined part
of our society I think of it as this
giant humonculon that runs on its own
economy that's somewhere between the
healthcare system and the former Soviet
Union
there's no rationality to it it just
rolls on its own and it's eating up more
and more of our young people's lives and
money and no there's no accountability
and I as an investigative reporter who
has written about in justices in other
segments of our society think we should
look at it we look at the health care
system why aren't we looking at this
well just before we go further give us a
sense of the resources that are being
spent and the scope of the
disestablishment well you know and who
is the numbers person I think he should
do that sure
almost half a trillion dollars as an
industry what concerns us most is that
students particularly undergraduate
students are far at the end of the line
the chief concern at colleges not just
universities but colleges to other
professors their lives their their
careers their perquisite s-- research
has given tremendous emphasis much more
than it should by the way we feel there
is too much research being done and one
of our you know suggestions is that it
be cut down I'll just give you an
example here I have some notes on this
now let me find it here oh yes
in a recent 14 year period now we all
love and reveal Revere William Faulkner
we certainly do
great American novels recent 14-year
period just ended 2781 papers were
written by professors on William
Faulkner I'll say that again 2781 Papers
written on William fuller did they have
to be Brittany no do they tell us
anything we need to know no why were
they written so that assistant
professors could be promoted to
associate professor and associate
professors could become full professors
now also because of this the students
aren't being taught for example there's
something you've heard of it called a
sabbatical ninety-eight percent of
americans do not get sabbaticals but
professors do take a small talk all
right start with Harvard Harvard at this
current academic year in its history
Department 20 of its professors are off
on paid leave 20 of its professors and
by the way this comes out of
undergraduates tuitions Harvard is
bleeding poor but the professors at way
at Williams College which is supposed to
emphasize undergraduates there's a nice
little religion
seven professors four of them are off on
leave this semester doing god-knows-what
indeed taking their place our visitors
who don't know anything about the campus
adjuncts who come and go if your
daughters of Williams and was thinking
of writing a senior thesis oh the
professor is often Provence now in other
words what we're saying is this has
become a bastion of privilege now it's
may I add it it's its privilege
alongside of exploitation because the
adjuncts who were not a factor when I
went to school I I had I don't believe I
had any adjuncts teaching me when I
studied at NYU in the sixties the
adjuncts are doing at many schools 70%
of the teaching they are paid something
like two to three thousand dollars of
course that is rank exploitation we talk
to adjuncts who probably were not making
minimum wage when you start figuring out
what it costs to work but higher
education particularly on the elite
levels to me looks like a board game and
the professors throw the dice and they
go around the board and the more famous
and the more rewards that's the word
they use you accumulate the less you
have to teach that's the goal of the
board game to teach as little as
possible so when I how did something as
satisfying as joyful as life-giving as
teaching becomes so debased in this
culture I don't understand it I love
teaching and yet it's considered almost
punishment within the culture of the
professorial
for example in take mathematics and by
the way we're supposed to be getting our
young people interested in mathematics
so we can eat the Chinese or whatever
we're supposed to do at American
universities today
only 10% of undergraduates are taught
their introductory mathematics course by
a regular faculty member 90% are taught
by graduate students and adjuncts who
come and go why aren't they talk by
bergen because of regular faculty feel
they're too good to teach freshmen and
sophomores they feel they are so
important in this field called
mathematics that they will not teach the
introductory course and because they
have tenure they cannot be made to teach
the introductory course in mathematics
which we very much support and if you
listen to the National Academies of
Sciences there's a great crisis in that
you know Americans don't want to do math
and don't want to do science and will we
ever beat the Chinese and yet this whole
area of undergraduate teaching is
completely neglected and thought to be
very much unimportant we have somebody
in the book who was in charge of
undergraduate teaching at a Midwest
College and he had nothing but overseas
graduate students who were doing the
teaching who didn't speak English very
well but for most American young people
calculus is already a foreign language
but if you have them taught by somebody
who really is new to the culture doesn't
speak English very well
you really have problems and when this
particular person who was in our book
said to his boss you know it's just so
unfair that the students you've got to
give our graduate teaching fellows 6
months of remedial English
the answer was that's too expensive but
most of the people doing the
undergraduate teaching as graduate
assistants are at this point in these
areas overseas oh yes
currently in engineering 60% of the PhDs
are to foreign students 60% over half
and by the way this is the enlarged
measure
those young Americans don't want to do
engineering why don't think of the kids
who start engineering education almost
half of them drop out why because
engineering teachers are the pits they
are the worst teachers we have they
don't care they are arrogant and nobody
blows the whistle on them in fact you
can't when people have tenure there's
nothing you can do about it at Harvard
for example where the teaching is really
terrible no yes they do every Ivy League
colleges in your school Harvard hides it
but it's got one we talked with a group
of undergraduates at Harvard and we
talked with undergraduates everywhere
and we asked them about their classes
they looked at us they were amused they
say no no we're majoring in the Harvard
Crimson
they were all working on the paper they
don't even go to the class they learn
from each other I think it a lot of the
elite schools the kids end up learning
from each other but let me get to this
thing about the professor's which you
know the kids are fine it's the
professor's we worry about Harvard's set
up a committee a commission no they call
a task force to investigate teaching at
Harvard because there are so many
complaints about how bad it was and you
know and the professor by the way the
task force was made up of professors
with named chairs you know Cabot Lodge
all those names they didn't have a
single student on the task force
not a single junior professor not a
single teaching assistant just these top
professors well they finally decided yes
some teaching needs improvement so they
suggested that professors be videoed
taped film and watch themselves in the
class that was a great idea but then
we've read further in the report and it
said but this should only be done for
junior non-tenured faculty that should
not make a graven image
yes we asked them and they said there's
no way we can ask a tenured professor to
allow film in his class and you began to
say who's this college for so all this
discussion of the insularity and
privilege in the ivory tower may make
some of our audience members think that
they walked into a seminar at Cato not
demos and and actually leads me to ask
the question of you know just how great
is that privilege and just have much
more accountability and competition do
we do we want I mean the the top
professor in their field if they're
really lucky may may make at the peak as
much money as your 25 year old law
associate might make at a corporate law
firm the entire payroll of a lot of
these academic departments is probably
not as great as what some you know 30
year old hedge fund managers make every
year and we live in a time in which
market forces are steamrolling over just
about every sector of our society so I
guess I anticipating some of the
audience questions I guess I want to put
the question to you you know why are you
picking on higher education as a place
where there's too much privilege and not
enough accountable just going for one
thing you said because David I'm afraid
you're dead wrong I forget the exact
page in there but a Yale professor makes
1,800 dollars an hour it's in the book
1,800 an hour a Yale professor teaches
what we call one and two one semester he
teaches one class and then poor guy has
to teach two classes the next semester
sabbatical every seven years not at Yale
every three years he's off so we figured
out because the Yale professor makes
over 200,000 a year on average you know
when you add in benefits and all the
rest we had we ended up all his
classroom
you know performance and all the rest
and we figured he is paid eighteen
hundred dollars for every hour he
teaches now if he says hey I have to
prepare my classes give the same
lectures over again and office hours
maybe if he's not consulting in Abu
Dhabi we're going to stick with 1,800 an
hour and I think that's not many lawyers
make that so when you add in all the
time you spent as a graduate student and
undergraduate as a lowly paid assistant
professor to get into that I mean do you
think that he's overpaid that it's not
Poverty Row and many professors senior
professors act as if they well one
person was telling me who is a senior
professor he has a brother who's a hedge
fund trader and Thanksgivings are hell
and his family because he is considered
the poor person but he's not at 200
thousand a year let's get real about
this this is not poverty row it's not
poverty row if you're working in an Ivy
League college making six figures
getting ten twenty percent of your
mortgage paid by the university getting
tuition remission for your kids
getting a sabbatical every three years
very few professions have those kind of
perks and yet this is filled with people
for some reason feel victimized I don't
understand it they are not coal miners
this for people at the top of the field
and that's a lot of people it is a very
good living
now maybe we now have come to live in a
society where everybody is so envious of
the very rich and wants to be that very
rich that they consider themselves poor
at two hundred thousand but I don't know
we might be a little more sympathetic if
they cared about the students that
function for example we were at one very
prestigious university and we were
talking with students there
he said oh yeah we I'm in a seminar with
14 students and and a professor full
professor and we said oh hey that's
pretty good and he said yeah well this
problem that full professor has a
full-time teaching assistant who reads
the seminar papers and grades them the
professor does not even read his
students seminar papers now if that
isn't malpractice I don't know what is
and I think one of the things that I if
I may speak for Andrew I when he began
teaching his in his career at Cornell
that it wasn't the case from everything
you've told me that even the biggest
stars taught an undergraduate section a
large one and I think maybe that's why
people come up to you on the street all
the time Andrew and say dr. hacker dr.
hacker I had you for government 101 at
Cornell in 1961 and I never forgot it
that's a great joy that's a great
pleasure and you know these mandarins
who is so aloof from the undergraduates
I don't get what they're about as people
I don't know why they're not giving
themselves in that way may I address
another point you made David that that
this is that we sound a bit like
conservatives when in fact perhaps
politically we're not
I don't think university reform in
higher education is a left-right issue
it may seem so and I think people on the
left and people on the right treat it
that way I think a lot of people on the
Left feel this is where our people went
to work and it's sacrosanct and you
can't criticize it I think a lot of
people on the right feel are there are
leftist let's get them but that neither
of that is really the issue the issue is
young people aren't getting treated
right in their education and they're
often made to indenture themselves for
the rest of their lives through these
student loans could I pickups with some
numbers on that yes please no okay
have this here since we use 1980 as a
base year 30 years ago not that far go
take a nice little college called Pomona
out in California's a good liberal arts
college its tuition is now two point
nine three times in real dollars its
tripled in real dollars since 1980
Williams College 3.2 University of
Southern California three point six
getting up to quadrupled in real dollars
now what's that money being spent on
well part of it is professor salaries in
that 30 year period
professor salaries I'd say Stanford have
gone up 64% in real dollars real people
the rest of us
well I'm sorry professor but real people
their wages have gone up in real dollars
5% in those last 30 years at Stanford
64% now you begin to ask why is it that
there are such valuable commodities
they'll leave to run hedge funds no
they're just there and they make the
kids pay now here's the second time
wider colleges raise tuition as they do
because you know it's up there tuition
itself 40,000 living away from home
another 15,000 were talking 55,000 just
for the year before you take a ski trip
the reason why they have felt colleges
but they can raise the salaries they
tell the students go take out loans and
this is what's new and this is what's
atrocious two-thirds of the students
getting B A's this year are graduating
in debt at the age of 22 sometimes as
much as 60 $70,000 in debt at the age of
22 why are they doing this because the
colleges keep ramping up their tuition
to pay the professors to teach or to not
to teach
and we won't even get into
administrators and football teams but
and it's the kids imagine this is like
sometime 22 year olds and a lot of them
are going to default it's hard to go
bankrupt because the bank's made sure
the bankruptcy is difficult in this you
know hi shadow to think what's going to
happen when these loans come due because
we know of a young woman who went to my
alma mater NYU with a full tuition
scholarship she thought she also had the
chance to go to SUNY Stony Brook she
wanted pre-med she feels she did not
have a good four years and in the
sciences at NYU because NYU is very good
in the arts but their undergraduate in
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences is
kind of ragged in my opinion and she
somehow graduated with 70,000 in death I
asked how she could do that with a full
scholarship and she explained it to me
and you know she didn't know about the
health insurance the price of the dorm
went up she didn't realize some of the
scholarship was work-study and and the
pre-med was difficult the long and the
short is she graduated with 60,000 and
then she had to take a deferment and
it's up to 70 I don't know if she's ever
going to get to medical school she said
to me very poignant Lee I wish I'd gone
to Stony Brook like the other kids in my
high school and that's leads to another
question why are parents so debasing the
idea of public higher education which is
far more efficient and is is cheaper and
is often a a very viable alternative I
think the answer is and there are
parents who are culpable in this its
snobbery and it's wrong know what I'm
gonna do dear even public education is
not that much cheaper okay you go to
Penn State tuition is fifteen thousand a
year that's a lot less than 40
but you're living away from home and the
price of court sorry the cost of room
for food and dorms has just escalated
it's twice what it used to be you know
and again in real dollars and for
example I have one we looked at menus at
various colleges one college offers by
the way remember some of you went to
college it used to be mr. e means in a
you know in a cafeteria with a metal
tray now you have at one College on the
menu
Dijon chicken butternut squash soup at
another college African couscous orange
junior to pho state to host state you
know this is for 18 and 19 year old
undergraduates part of it is the arms
race with amenities that colleges feel
they have to offer this at University of
Houston five-story
climbing wall all that's in the tuition
Washington State a public university has
a jacuzzi that holds 50 student bodies
you know that's again higher education
Kenyon College nice little college in
Gambia Ohio built a seventy million
dollar athletic Emporium it has a 20
Lane swing pool imagine 20 now what's
paying for this you know that's why I to
ition is going up I'm going to get into
your reform proposals in a second but
first I wonder if you could address this
question I've long had about higher
education which is why is it that
institutions which aren't answerable to
shareholders do not have a bottom line
and the corporate sense behave in such a
rapacious fashion as you describe they
are exploiting their their adjunct that
their adjunct professors that sort of
it's it's it's very much of a sweatshop
environment they won't let them unionize
and
number of schools and as you've just
described they're kind of up selling and
exploiting their consumers and there's a
tremendous even among the tenured
faculty tremendous inequality and a star
system just like you might find in the
private sector so I'm wondering what are
the dynamics that turn these non profit
institutions into institutions that
behave in many of the same ways as
corporations well we sometimes think if
they only behave like corporations it
would be a little more rational there's
no accountability the way I see it is
it's a giant machine that just rolls on
its own energy and its own dynamics no
one ever says no and it's since it's
particularly unregulated and it's
outside even the minimal regulations
that corporations have and it even the
market doesn't exactly function there I
think has just happened for their own
reasons and again the only analogy I can
that people could get their arms around
perhaps is the health care system which
functions similarly but even the health
care system is somewhat more rational I
think just things happen people make
their careers by proposing grandiose
schemes they nobody's ever accountable
when they fail the economics for
instance of the elite Ivy's right now
who've lost so much money with the
craziest wildest speculation that no
sensible organization should have
engaged in a who pays for it
no one really does and then they raise
their tuition and then they say oh well
most of our students come here on
scholarships I don't know how many times
I've heard that story rationalizing the
high tuition in the Ivy's but what's
never said is that when Harvard raises
its tuition it raises the tuition for
the whole system everybody follows can I
add one it's not a it's not scholarships
it's
we call them discounts it's they say hey
no it's 40,000 for the sticker price
we'll take 5,000 off for you and they
call that a scholarship for financial
aid but I'll give you a simple answer
David as to why colleges have us in
their grip only they can offer and
bestow a bachelor's degree and this is
the great marker in American society
here it goes
vertical on one side are the people with
bachelor's degrees on the other side
people who don't have them if there's
any class system that's it now parents
and in many cases their youngsters what
the parents certainly want their kids to
have a BA if they don't have a BA my god
your kid will end up pleased to call it
the Bowery you know I'm not sure what
the current counter part of it is also
the parents are willing to mortgage
mortgage their own kids future to get
that bachelor's degree
now the bachelor's degree doesn't offer
you you know soaring up to the firmament
but it will least keep you on that side
of the divide even with unemployment
today you know bachelors have half the
rate as non bachelors now what we'd add
to this is we have a chapter which we
entitled the golden dozen we picked out
12 colleges the Ivy League they're eight
of them they are and then Stanford Duke
Amherst and Williams these are places
where proper upper-middle class
professional parents want their kids to
be for example they're at the Country
Club that people still go to country
clubs and somebody asks them where is
Jennifer now if you're able to say
Jennifer is at Yale you get a
congratulatory nod and smile
if you were to say that Jennifer is a
Earlham College you get oh and then you
have to explain Earlham really has very
good internship sir so by the way oh yes
you said the University of North Dakota
what would you get you wouldn't you
wouldn't even be in the Country Club
now what we did was we one of the things
so there a lot of parents are paying for
the prestige they really are because
they hope that this will loft their
child up not just with a BA but to the
top of the be a list well I won't go
into this in a detail but we decided to
study one class of students from a
golden dozen school okay what is
Princeton
we picked the Princeton class which had
913 students admitted and we tracked
them all the way through Princeton and
then into their later life and gave them
enough time to you know which I say make
a mark in life Princeton's mantra is we
produce national leaders and it is true
they have produced Ralph Nader F scott
Fitzgerald he's a leader Eugene O'Neill
Jeff Bezos of Amazon not Aronson Wilson
yes Donald Rumsfeld hey Princeton has
88,000 graduates it's found out at least
one Rumsfeld now but we looked at this
class of 900 and I'm afraid they
disappointed us there really weren't
national leaders there nobody was a CEO
nobody was a federal judge they turned
out to be rather average and this in
wait made me feel rather good because it
meant that certain Princeton people are
kind of downwardly mobile not to the
Bowery but downloaded mobile whereas
people from my Queens College are coming
up and passing them
I'm sorry to report that half of the
billionaires who've made their fortune
and finance have degrees from just three
of the top business schools so there's
there's actually a one out of ten
billionaires in America I graduated from
Harvard University so I think that there
is some no that's the data that's the
business schools if you mean Wharton
Harvard and Columbia now actually the
business schools are very good about
taking in a catchment from people from
okay one more thing just on the book we
looked at Harvard Law School we did
research we really did we took eight
years of Harvard Law School and we
looked at the 3,000 students who were
admitted to Harvard Law School in that
eight-year period by the way Harvard and
we want to know what undergraduate
colleges they went to Harvard didn't
want to give us this information but I
have friends who got it and what we
found was that Harvard Law School works
at both ways half of their places are
reserved for the golden dozen you know
our tightest but the other half of
harbors admissions are from everywhere
Valparaiso State College Valdosta in
Georgia Linfield in Oregon and one of
the things we say is if you go to live
view or Valdosta and you do well there
and the professor's like you and they
write letters for you Harvard Law School
and Harvard Business School will admit
you and that's why we have no problems
saying go to a lesser-known school I
want to get to you to the audience
questions in a moment but first I want
to make sure that you have a chance to
talk about some of your perform reform
proposals because I know you have some
some pretty provocative suggestions so I
guess I'd like to start with the
question of tenure and your proposal to
abolish tenure or scale it back and
obviously
you're dealing with a giant system as
complex as this and we know this from
the healthcare reform efforts that there
isn't a single fix that's going to solve
things and this I personally feel that
higher education is far more complex
than healthcare as a system so that but
we we sat with each other and we said
well what could what are some some steps
that could fix things and the the thing
that obviously came forward was
abolished tenure and it's not that we
think we were going to Harold in the
dark ages of the Spanish Inquisition and
bring back McCarthyism but we really
looked at it and we did not see a lot of
examples of a protecting actual freedom
of expression I it's more like an
employment perk than it is anything else
and a very good one at that but there
are lots of schools that or there are at
least some that don't have tenure and
the dark ages haven't descended we'd
like to see perhaps tenure replace with
the long term contracts because
obviously you're asking people to move
to rural situations or different towns
and you certainly for recent real
research scientific research for
instance you need a long term commitment
but this thing of lifetime employment we
think is deadly and I have to tell you
wherever we went students told us that
their favorite professors were not the
tenured ones those were the ones who as
you would expect tended not to care and
tended to leave it up to the students
they said the adjuncts were their
favorite professors but the adjuncts are
on a treadmill just trying to survive
and can't really serve them as they
should they often don't even have
offices and we think that what protects
freedom of expression has a lot more to
do with whether or not presidents
exercise real leadership what
is another question in addition to
ending tenure axe could I just pick one
thing on tenure here
academic freedom that protects it just
the opposite if you take the young
people who are going into the academic
profession first its graduate students
and then as assistant professors they
are careful control cautious
they don't say a single thing that might
get them in trouble with anyone in other
words this tenure this quest for tenure
squelches them and by the time they
reach the age of 40 and they finally get
tenure the stuffs been wrung out of now
once you give people tenure in most
colleges they never leave part of the
reason is nobody wants them but they
never leave we studied three colleges
nice small ones
Middlebury Bowdoin and Reid two thirds
of the faculty there have been there at
least 25 years at least 25 years and
many more in other words you get a
graying faculty of tenured people to
spend all the time debating great
academic issues like the allocation of
parking spaces no we really think it's
bad for education 98% of Americans
including I think yourself David don't
have tenure and they get by
they really do maybe it brings out
something this is a cool do you know how
many people have academic tenure in this
country 300,000 we're not just talking
about Yale and Princeton everywhere
about us to state Sonoma State 300,000
people have this clue that nobody else
has so of course they're gonna scream
bloody murder if you want to take it
away from them they'll tell us we're
McCarthy eyes well we ran tight to
lecture
oh I'm sorry yes we're doing let me ask
about the broader accountability issue
of you know as you said this is sort of
a giant machine in your words out of
control
nobody is accountable
to anybody what are some possible
mechanisms for accountability and and
accountable to who and how well you know
again to go to the state schools most
university presidents at state colleges
do function under some constraints from
the legislators and it gets
they have very difficult relationships
with their state legislators but there
is more accountability as difficult as
it is I don't have a master plan to
solve this but I can see what's wrong
and I think maybe one of the answers is
we citizens have to become better
consumers just like we did in health
care now thirty years ago people didn't
ask their doctors any questions and
people when they got crazy bills from
the hospitals didn't ask the hospital's
questions and I don't know a person in
the room probably has been hospitalized
whoever has gotten a normal bill from a
hospital afterwards but you know now to
ask about it
when you notified with them and you know
to negotiate and we don't do that with
higher ed so I think one of the things
that has to happen is higher ed
consumers have to start thinking of
themselves that way but I think also
parents and students have to change in
what they demand of the universities I
snuck onto an awful lot of parents trips
at universities and you know the season
is almost beginning away they take these
tours of New England I snuck on to a lot
of those and the parents really asked
unbearable questions they never had I
never heard once anyone asked about
teaching parking space dorms equipment
the size of the swimming pool were their
stables at the college I mean were they
auditioning the kids for Club Med I mean
there has to be some discernment there
too I never
once people ask what kind of professors
do you have here can I go to a lecture
nor did the universities particularly
offer their star professors as lectures
to say you know this is our product this
is what we're putting out no they're
sending them to this very lavish
four-year emancipation where they they
get sports and lavish living and
geniality and they become better more
sociable people but if you asked me
that's not how to keep up with China by
the way they don't get sports just
taking the University of Illinois
you know big State University has a
bunch of athletic teams only 3% of the
Illinois University of students are on
an athletic team only 3% and I'm
including volleyball the other 97% are
supposed to sit and cheer in the
stadiums and maybe grow obese now but
Claudia okay
got me thinking about something here
State Legislators you know if I were a
member of the state legislature let's
say in the state of Missouri I would ask
the state of Missouri which by the way
has not just a flagship but has about 10
other regional universities why it is
that forty percent of the freshmen you
admit never get a degree in other words
a forty percent dropout rate only 60
percent end up to the BAS and I would
say to them what are you doing wrong and
don't blame the students well part of it
you know
are you teaching them are you being
interesting teachers this is the whole
thing we haven't got into during our
travels we always went to classes and we
always sat in classrooms and we watch
the teaching and as a result we have a
chapter which is entitled teaching :
good great and abysmal and we saw
teaching
we just felt so sorry for the students
it wasn't the professor's weren't
prepared all they read from their script
or sorry the powerpoints
oh don't worry ask them to that if
higher education looks now in the
futures if it's going to be in the dark
shades down lights out powerpoints but
and this is important question and I'm
not sure do it how do you make better
teachers you know I really think the
teachers in 3rd grade and 11th grade are
better teachers than our college
teachers you know and I'm worried about
this because so many professors would
then just don't have the temperament for
being an interesting teacher see I think
the kind of person who makes a good
scholar may not be the kind of person
who makes a good teacher um not in every
case we're talking about thousands of
people but very often a lot of people
become academics because yes the
stereotype is true they're introverted
they're good scholars they don't want to
relate to people and for them what
you're gonna turn me into a performer
I'm not a comedian are not Seinfeld they
look down on people who are actually
good communicators with their students
well there's something wrong there it's
a bad match but I think if the culture
of the University value teaching
strongly if that were said to be not
just lip service but really job one it
would change last question before we go
to the audience to to to too many young
people go to college today or too few
the Jeffersonians right okay Claudia and
I are it's amazing gonna write the book
you can only write a book together if
you really agree on fundamentals we are
both born-again Jeffersonians we both
believe we know everyone has a mind
everyone else
everyone has curiosity and we're talking
now let's take just an age group oh we
believe everyone if they want to do is
capable of college work now we're not
going to force them into it some people
might be better going back at the age of
28 or 30 we understand that but if you
have good teachers and we've seen enough
to know that it's possible they can
awaken even people who went to the
crummiest high schools you know it's a
too easy to blame K through 12 uh uh you
know there's a friend of mine who
teaches at my college which is a City
College and he said friends of his
asking are your students any good with a
kind of a sneer and he replies I make
them good
I totally agree I had wonderful students
when I taught at City College and I have
wonderful students at Columbia some of
the work there tonight thank you for
coming well I guess you know there's a
common critique out there that it's it's
hard to find people in the trades and a
lot of places you can't find a good
plumber or electrician or do you think
that there should be more emphasis on
preparing people for trade jobs like you
see in Germany more vocational education
and less emphasis on this sort of you
this ideal of universal as we watch
plumbers who have read Plato Aristotle
Jane Austen and Joyce Carol Oates and
Simone de Beauvoir okay well I think
that's a good note to go to questions
let's start back here thank you
I'm Charles Cobb with the committee for
economic disclosure and and and this
committee for economic development but
quite a point of full disclosure here I
happen to be a member of that dud class
of 1973 at Princeton and notwithstanding
all the wonderful things you said about
my classmates I want to thank both of
you for writing the book I told Andrew
and Claudia I read it a month ago on my
Kindle it is absolutely superb and I
hope all of you will will read it you
raise very important points at an
extremely important time when a lot of
questions are being raised about
post-secondary education my question is
this in all of your research and
conversations did you ever run into
people in the post-secondary endeavor
who approached it from the perspective
of human capital in other words if you
look at the billions of dollars that are
being spent in post-secondary education
whether it's private for-profit
not-for-profit Kaplan etc do people
actually think about training young
people from the perspective of human
capital the jobs they're going to have
and their ability to be effective
citizens in our
ah cracy thank you well I think there
are many things going on there there
everything's going on it's such a big
system and there are people who think
that way but there are also I think the
main thing that happens on campus is
this life of its own
dynamic things just happen it's like in
the health care system where you'll have
one County with five MRIs and nobody
knows why and so there isn't really a
guiding sense of mission to most
colleges and universities you'll
sometimes get a leader who has a guiding
sense of his or her own mission which is
to build another stadium or to expand
the real estate of the school or to get
a graduate school that the school
doesn't really need to produce more
unemployed phd's which we're producing
2/3 too many of um but they there isn't
this real sense of this part of our
system being a tool of democracy which
we think inherently it is I mean if we
have a really educated smart citizenry
you don't have to train them in
citizenship they will know it themselves
they will know how to think because
they've been exposed to for the best
that humankind has has created but we're
not doing that now and and even in the
job-training kind of areas which we
oppose a lot of it is just silly and
trendy you know it there'll be one
school that gets into doing CSI training
because lots of kids want it they
watched the series on TV there aren't
even that many jobs in the area but this
West Virginia public university had a
huge CSI department they'll be doing a
golf management bachelor's degrees and a
lot of sports management since people
like sports and particularly people at
university seem to like sports but I
they there's no rhyme or reason to
almost anything that happens in this
sector you know human capital one of the
reasons why we favor
ideally liberal arts for everyone is
because it doesn't focus you on
computers or on golf management for that
matter what we simply say it what at one
point somebody asked was what's your
ideal for these young people how what
should they be like when they come out
and I found myself saying I'd like them
to be interesting people yeah why not
you know and I am feeling that if you
have interesting people that's going to
be capital some of them will be poets
you know like Oscar Wilde hey that's
interesting and by the way there's quite
a wild industry now so I think here I'm
not sure that even the academic world at
this point is prepared to poo is ready
as the equipment to prepare people for
the next generation economically because
I'm not sure there's that much
brainpower and they're directed that but
I'm willing to keep an open mind on that
question down here
I hope I can figure out my notes I feel
like I've been sitting in class I have
been teaching for the last I guess it's
nine or ten years as an adjunct at a
local university and I've been horrified
to see that there are a number of
adjuncts who teach at more than one
school and they come in our faculty
lounge and they look harried and they
meet students and teach their classes
and then they run to the next school and
I don't see how that can be good for
anybody but it's happening the last year
that I've taught which was last year and
I got sick before the semester was over
I don't think the students had anything
to do with it I'm not really sure but
for both semesters last year I taught
students who the department chairman
asked me if I would be willing to do
this students who came in at a very low
end of performance and I felt like it
was hopeless I've been teaching lots of
years I started many years ago in
Virginia and an elementary school I
don't think I had students in elementary
school all those years ago who were as
poorly prepared as these kids I taught
last year it was just amazing they were
discipline problems as well as
intellectual challenges and I don't know
what the answer is there
I'm glad to hear about born-again
Jeffersonians because
and that's that's good to hear
it seems to me that we have lost our
appreciation for the liberal arts and
this is where we need to be focusing
because we need to know language and we
need to know history and we need to have
an appreciation of the arts and then we
can do these other things but if we can
only do the other things I think the
future
I feel really discouraged for probably
the first time in my life because it
seems to me that the outlook is not good
and I don't know maybe it's because I've
been sick and I'm just not or something
but anyway thank you just to take one
part of that that comment and ask about
that this plight of the adjunct
professor and the exploitation of this
pool of labor in the overproduction of
PhDs
by the academic system when there's not
jobs out there creating a bigger and
bigger pool I mean it's kind of a
classic kind of capitalist exploitation
model right and so I wonder what can be
done to change that insidious dynamic
well for starters all these tenured
faculty members with self-governance
should make part of their platform not
accepting the underpayment of their and
the exploitation of the adjunct faculty
you know that the tenured raises
happened in tandem with the taking on of
this this migratory labor pool it
happened at the same time and what when
you talk to tenured faculty they have
the same rationalizations that you would
hear about other kinds of exploitation
they're not as good or they see them as
invisible they are rude to them almost
every adjunct that I've talked to in in
in the course of doing that chapter
which was mostly one of those chapters
that I wrote we sometimes divided tests
it they always said to me you know not
only are we underpaid but everyone is
always rude to us
even the secretaries know we're lower on
the scale on the pecking order they're
rude to us just the lack of dignity and
that's part of it
but the there's a leading to the
problems of teaching unprepared students
you can't have people who are working at
6 or 7 classes in a semester in order to
just pay the rent have the time and the
patience to work with people who do need
more more help so I think these things
feed into each other and they're not
separate you know there's one there's
several but one reasoning for the
overproduction of graduate students and
PhDs
professors get status points for
teaching graduate students and graduate
seminars you do not get status points
for teaching sophomores as a result
professors attract as many graduate
students as they can to fill up their
seminars so they can supervise their
dissertations have you know disciples
for their discipline by the way one of
the reasons why we bring in 700,000
foreign students or they're almost from
other places almost all in the sciences
and engineering so that the professor's
can fill up their seminars if we didn't
have those overseas students the
professor's would have to teach
undergraduates and that would be the
kiss of death
and so those those overseas students who
come very often come as graduate
teaching assistants that's part of what
you do if you're a graduate student
and that's where the entropy and the
miss teaching also happens because they
don't have the language skills it's it's
a cycle that just keeps feeding itself
by the way just one last statistic on
this I'm going to tell you how many
universities in this country award phd's
know many you think it's Harvard Yale
Princeton Michigan 280 universities
award doctorates that includes eastern
Tennessee southern Kentucky northern
Missouri you know and why because the
professors get status by supervising
doctoral students and a newly installed
university president will say we need a
graduate school or like we need a
stadium you you just don't make points
as a president by not building things
let's get to two or three questions on
the table just so we had right back
there my name is Phyllis Weiss has Errol
and my professional work is on him
focused on improving the working
relations among the generations in the
workplace so we are concerned with how
people are prepared by way of
introduction I was the government major
Cornell and one of your students so and
my son went to Arizona State so which is
one of the schools that you selected as
being ones that you like my question
however is something else related to
tenure and such the demographics are
that one-third of the faculties of
universities will be eligible for
retirement in the next ten years so I'm
wondering if you see that as an
opportunity for changing the tenure
system or will it be a problem because
everybody is going to be running after
the stars and so they will continue to
offer them more
more perks and all these incentives how
do you think that will be affecting when
you have a third of the faculties
changing over let's hold that answer and
take get two more questions yes the one
that's you know when I went shopping for
a car as an 18 year old I didn't know
anything about cars I would not know
what questions to ask when I was buying
something whether it be college or a car
but there's this magazine consumer
reports which will gladly tell you
everything about what you don't know and
which ones are good and which ones are
bad do you think there should be
something like a Consumer Reports for
universities and colleges I know there's
the US News and World Report's which
will tell you which are more expensive
in which order they will tell you what
other university presidents think of
each other yes which is just you know
thinking Mercedes is good without
actually testing it and yes well it's
down low telecom we had it then we had a
question here just wait for the mic
please
my name is Carol's foamer and I have a
question anything very quick comment um
the question is you've talked about how
they can infer their increase or expense
by paying adjuncts more and I was an
adjunct and I couldn't live on the money
so although they want me to continue I
just couldn't do that
before but that's the aside the question
is in what ways do you realistically see
them able start cutting the budget and
reducing the need for tuition increases
for students well I think if they
increase adjuncts pay it wouldn't it
wouldn't break the system I my my first
job in the 60s one of my first Jobs was
as a union organizing for the drug in
hospital workers here in New York who
worked at poverty wages without question
they were exempt from all the minimum
wage benefits and and laws because they
weren't worked for nonprofits once they
union I
and and we're able to get more
recognition for their needs the
hospitals didn't go out of business now
some of them do father reasons but that
wasn't it
and I think if they paid living wages to
to to this educated migrant workforce it
wouldn't break the neither the first
thing they'd have to start doing to save
money is not do these expensive caprices
that includes sports that includes or
any crazy thing you know as a center in
one of the emirates that Michigan State
opened up or that George Mason also
opened up and they didn't even know who
they were dealing with they didn't know
the names of their co-investors I mean
where what what world does that happen
in no wonder they went out of business
these are public universities that had
to close down these overseas branches
when they weren't taking care of
business at home okay let me give you
just there are so many places you could
cut whether you do it is another story
for example University of Texas has a
volleyball team well okay but when you
add in flying off to play in tournaments
and all the rest I didn't believe this I
had to read this three times and make a
phone call University of Texas spends
fifty seven thousand dollars a year on
each volleyball player that's you know
imagine and why do we have Ollie ball
it's a liberal art well alright let's
take the guy's sports the average size
of football squads from 1982 to present
the average size of a football squad has
grown from 82 players to a hundred two
players they have added 20 players
measured how the bench has to be
expanded why because the coach has such
esoterics strategies that he needs a
hundred two players to
there are 629 college football teams
only 14 of them cover their cause we
could get rid of them we recommend we
give high star ratings to Haverford
Swarthmore Brandeis Emery Marquette
because they all got rid of football if
you can do that you can hire a lot of
assistant professors and pay your
adjuncts better just a just a minute or
two left there was some other questions
that were asked about whether this is an
opportunity to break the back at the
tenure system and also whether we need
some kind of Consumer Reports to ensure
more accountability if you could address
that we need consumers consumers
consumers reports as part of consumers
union and we need we need educational
consumers to ask questions by the way
when I bought my first car I was as
ignorant as you but I brought Fred along
with me my pal
because he knew cars and cars don't you
have a friend named Fred
ah come on
we bought used cars but but I you know I
think the strategy parents need to do it
now isn't isn't simple you need to ask
people about good experiences there are
good people in every institution and
there are awful people
and there are good situations and bad
ones so you need to be smart and you
need to not get caught up in the
prestige game we have some really
innovative smart strategies which we
suggest for parents because we think
that avoiding debt is much more
important than accumulating prestige and
when I've mentioned some of our ideas to
colleagues they act like I'm suggesting
child abuse but we think that somebody
beginning life without owing seventy
thousand dollars is better off than
going to a fancy school where they've
got Dijon chicken but I'd love to hear
more from you than from us because one
of the things we've discovered since we
began writing our book that promoting
the book is the stories we've heard from
people and the information we've gotten
it's so much even more and stronger than
what we felt when we were writing it
that we could write a second book just
out of what we've learned on our book
tour I had one thing about the Consumer
Reports here's what I suggest
every College now puts online their
student evaluations of professors I
haven't be professor who was in favor of
student evaluations and by the way if
you want to see some of mine just google
me and for some reason on my first page
are my Queens College evaluations some
of them are scathing some of them think
I'm st. Andrew okay that tells you a bit
but hey the students we won't call them
consumers or customers we're not gonna
call in patients the students are Stu
they are entitled to have a view they're
entitled to expect good teaching and if
they don't get it and they want to type
it out
good read them you'll get a good picture
of the college and by the way well no
that's enough somebody somebody
mentioned that they felt like they were
in class this evening I think we'd all
agree it's been a very well taught class
the book is called higher education with
a big question mark you can buy it at
the back of the room or on Amazon I want
to thank our speakers for coming out
tonight and thank all year andrew hacker
is a political science professor
emeritus at Queens College he's also a
regular contributor to the New York
Review of Books
Claudia Dreyfus is a media professor at
Columbia University's School of
International and public affairs and a
senior fellow at the world Policy
Institute for more information visit
higher education question mark calm and